hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a final round game from the 16th U.S
championship
this is really a historic game
this event took place towards the tail
end of 1963 and even spilled into the
new year
on the wide end we have international
Master Dr Anthony Sadie and he's playing
against Bobby Fischer
it's the result of this final round game
that's set an unbreakable record
let's have a look
English opening symmetrical English
and with this game I'm going to pay
special attention to one phase
the end game
the opening in Middle game just some
light points we kind of fast forward
through those phases many exchanges
early on in this one brings us quickly
to the end game phase
alright from here D4 C takes D4
Knight takes D4
and on this move 5 E6
one of those proceed with caution type
moves
D6 is now a hole and white is quick to
eye it up with Knight D to B5 both
Knight and Queen have an eye on D6
Bishop B4
in reply to this move white plays A3
however
do know that if this guy jumps into D6
black should not take the Knight
if you're capturing the Knight
this queen is very good on D6 and even
if challenge she could be reinforced
Queen on D6 a bishop on D6
would be fantastic for what
so black is in other words prepared
to go on Castle diff Knight D6 Black's
prepared to play King E7
this isn't the most testing continuation
from here but if Knight takes
this bishop black is for choice
has great development no way to get it
this uncastled King black will soon
press with D5
my point don't be so quick as black to
part ways with your good Bishop for a
knight
now just as I say this after A3 the move
played in the game we do have
the good Bishop being exchanged for a
knight however this pulls
this invasive Knight away
from this weakest squared D6 and now
black is able to play D5
so this early
positional assault you might say on the
D6 square has been neutralized
okay in black is even ready to
give this Knight a shove
easily parried
white continues with E3
castles
C takes d
e takes D lact takes on
isolated Pawn opens up
a lane for the bishop and there's an
half open file now for a rook
light Square Bishops around
light focuses on controlling the square
right in front of the isolated Pawn
usually a good plan
Queen B6 also with an ion controlling of
that square
White Castles Knights given a kick to D4
Knight takes Knight Queen takes Knight
and here we go
a ram structure on board officially
and end game
no queens couple minor pieces each a
couple Rooks still on board black with
this last move looking to get to the
dream rank
okay trying to get to C2 denied
black tries to get in there though or
Bishop to C2
and the reply to this is Bishop to E3
now the suggestion by the engine is to
duck the light Square Bishop exchange to
play Bishop F3 we would have some kind
of back and forth like this in general
it's probably a good idea for white to
duck the light Square Bishop exchange
playing with the bishop pair
try to preserve the Bishops uh in this
specific environment another reason for
this is you're not allowing the black
Rook to get to the second rank so easily
okay in this game
Bishop E3
and this game Bishop to E3 is played
knowing that
uh White Knows by playing Bishop to E3
he will be able to deal with a black
Rook on the second rank so there's some
uh several moves deep white has
calculated with Bishop to E3 let's see
what that calculation is exactly after
Bishop takes Bishop
Rook F takes that's the
correct Rook to take with it is the end
game the king now has access to F1 he's
ready to quickly approach
first things first though black gets to
the second rank in white must challenge
that rook and does with Rook D2
black doubles Rook takes Rook Rook takes
Rook how is white supposed to defend the
pawn
indirectly Rook C1 this is what white
had calculated when he played move 18
Bishop E3 he knew he could
indirectly defend B2 if black takes
White's gonna have Checkmate in two
so the Rooks come off and here we are
already after 23 moves
for sure an end game on board Knight
versus Bishop who is better
black is better
why is this well before I go any further
I'm going to throw this to you
and ask how would you approach this end
game night vs Bishop what would be your
next move or two or three what's your
plan here as black
if you'd like to go ahead pause the
video see what you would come up with
okay
Fisher's plan he says to himself first
things first let me get my knight to a
magic square
where's the magic square
E6 how do I know it's a magic square how
do I also know that black is for Choice
here
when in general the bishop is supposed
to be better than the Knight I'll touch
on that shortly
he's focused on maneuvering the Knight
now you may think end game
we bring our King towards the center yes
that's a good approach as well but his
focus is on getting to an optimal Square
for the night and that is the optimal
Square
why
well
it coordinates really well with this guy
on D5
a night on a light Square
a Pawn on a light Square they control
both color complexes
look at how they're working together the
pawn has light and the Knight positioned
on a light Square controls the dark
covered covered covered covered
covered
the king could never move here how does
the white king get to Black's side of
the board
maybe trying to sneak over here
to this Square no problem B6 could
always be played all of these squares
are under Black's control and these two
key pieces the Knight on E6 and Pawn on
D5
they are stable they cannot be
influenced
and black black could even think about
going one step further positioning
another Pawn on F5 taking away another
Square on G4 how does the white king
ever cross
into black side of the board
if he can't get to Black side of the
board he's not going to pose any serious
threat to Black
that's how I know this is a position
that uh you know black is for Choice
Black's the one playing for two results
a win or a draw because of this optimal
Square for the night being so effective
okay
the reply here is King to D3 and after
this move 26
I have a very nice photo to share with
you I believe this photo right here was
snapped right or shortly after
King D3 was played
Fisher on the left versus
Sadie here I believe Fisher is on move
from what I could gather from the photo
um
yeah interesting to kind of take all of
this in here seeing the
the lamp right next to the players
Fishers in thought I believe right about
now here trying to figure out what his
plan is now that he has his Knight on E6
how to activate the king is probably
running through his mind what is the
plan here what is what gives me the best
chance of success how to possibly
convert this
okay let's see what his try is
he goes with H5
now in general good idea again to keep
pawns playing on the black side here put
pawns on dark squares
the advancing two with this guy he's
opening up a square for the king
now just a little bit ago I was touching
on the F5 advance but this F5 Square
might be a square
the black king wants to make use of
where it's more Central
so he's opening up a door for the king
he's going
two squares with the H Pawn
and now he has King H7
so let's see the attempt here we
eventually get to a point where
no Black's not quite sure exactly how to
approach we have a little bit of a back
and forth
let's see how the pawns are set up
really I should also mention this when
this Knight is here this Pawn is here
the board is kind of cut in half we're
really only focused in this end game
on one side of the board we're focused
on the king side this is where there is
uh where it can vary we're not quite
sure how the pawns will be positioned
for either side there's some variety
left with the pawn advances for each
side
the queen side of the board not so much
it kind of comes to a dead end
so how is the king side play going to
shape up
okay he ends up backing off with the
king king's coming back
in the end he ends up coming up with the
F Pawn advancing right now and he's
ready to go and position this guy right
here on F4 so this does I believe
provide black with the best
possible winning chances
for you know several of these moves
white was just holding his ground
um watching over this one weak point
let's see the the progress here
Black's looking to reposition this
Knight next
to F5
this does place a restriction in at
least one of these two pieces keeps an
eye on D4 and now the only what the only
attempt here really
is to play on the the king side here
with the break G4 hits
H takes G HG FG
and now the Knight is one move out from
immediately getting this Pawn back
Knight H6
so up until this point it has been an
even game
but with this play on the king side it
does now Force an error a fatal error
here for white
in the game
Bishop E1 is played and it's now a win
for black
and it's held like that for the rest of
the game
now there is a draw here I want to touch
on what the drawing method would be for
white in this position
there's all it's a narrow path there is
an only move here for white
and that only move is King to E2
let's see how white could draw this
position instead of the move in the game
Bishop E1 it's King E2
Knight takes pawn and the bishop goes to
G1 a very important move another only
move for white
this bishop is on his back foot
but doing a good enough job of
restricting the knights forward moves
all forward moves
if King F3
I'm sorry if King F5 King F3 and where
do you go from here as black
piece by piece comparison Bishop knocks
out the night Bishop controls the Knight
white King Controls the black king we
certainly do not want to allow
the black king to get to E4 I was
pointing out a a magic square for the
night earlier on maneuvering to E6 well
if this guy could establish himself on
e4 that would be golden
next up all you would have to do is
maneuver the Knight to attack that pawn
and you're going to be winning that pawn
if this guy is here
but now what would you play here is
black to make progress again this is a
the drawing method white hat available
to him there really isn't a great
attempt here
we could look at the different options
suppose King G5
or
let's say B6 or A6 I'll just pick one of
them if B6 is played
this is how white could continue
G3 and these guys get exchanged
and this square is not available to
Black because the King has a
responsibility to defend the Knight
King E4 King takes Knight
so exchanging the kingside pawns like
this would be helpful
for white because there's then there
would then be one less Square
taken away from the white king he'd be
able to Pivot on these these two squares
and the king is never able to enter on
e4 in the Night by definition could
never control a light and dark square at
the same time so the white king would
always have access to one of these two
any other attempt in this position here
is black there is one other one to look
at
this move this move and this move can
all be met with G3
however
if Knight F6 in this position G3 would
be losing
G3 Chop Chop the king gets here
this Knight could follow a similar path
as he did earlier getting to E6 and this
Pawn will be one
however white could still draw this not
with G3
but with Bishop to H2 immediately
putting pressure on this Pawn
that's the drawing method and how do you
defend the pawn
Knight H5 could now be met with A5 and
you see what just happened everything is
basically Frozen now on black side
what do you do can't move any of your
Pawns
okay you shouldn't move in this Pawn you
can't move the Knight you drop the pawn
you're down to moving your king and you
can't go wherever you want with the King
you have to go here to stay trained on
this point but now you're not one square
away from E4 now
white will be able to play G3 and we
would get this liquidated position for
instance and this would be a drawn King
in Pawn end game
we're observing here
a key difference between having the
bishop on G1 and E1 okay in this game
Bishop E1 is played
Knight takes G4
and these next handful of moves by white
are Bishop moves
he goes Bishop to D2
if the king tries to go to E2 in this
position you know just one move later
it's not the same King E2 King F5
King F3 stops King E4 but because the
bishop is on E1 and not G1
the Knight has access to H2
check
and the king is kicked away from
defending E4 the king gets to the golden
Square the magic square and this guy
will soon be one black goes on to win
big difference here
Bishop on E1 versus G1 it's really
important to have this check covered by
the bishop
okay
how does the game continue Bishop D2
black enters Bishop E1
maneuvering the Knight Knight E4
Bishop back King improves and now
King to E2 Knight G3 check
this Knight can't be captured should not
be captured
Bishop takes Knight would be met with
King takes bishop and this would be a
one king and pawn ending
King F1 we push and this guy is way out
of position this Pawn will soon be
hunted
so you can't go straight into a king and
pawn ending
and you must make a decision then with
the King
in the game King D3 is played
so your choices here are to
stay close to the G Pawn
try and defend the G Pawn or the d-pawn
in the game after King D3 black in just
a few moves ends up going after the G
pawn and wins the G Pawn
so
what's the other try if the King goes
here what's the winning plan
this is very instructive King F2 could
be met with Knight F5
hitting this Pawn only one way to defend
it and now Knight to E3
what do you do about Knight D1 check
you don't really have much Choice here
if you move the bishop you're going to
end up losing this Pawn to a fork
and if you move the pawn you're going to
lose the bishop to the fork
what other options are there here for
white if you just sit
let's say for instance make a pawn move
we would land this check
you could actually exchange into this
ending
and this is considered
a win here for team black it may be a
little bit scary for sure
this idea of white playing C4
but that's the that would be the only
try here if you're if you're not trying
C4 right here making a king move this
king is already close and there's no
fear of the C4 advance but let's have a
look at this variation right here
where we trade into a king and pawn
specific ending and this ID of C4 black
is winning
after this sequence the capture
let's say push push Black's ready to
promote with checks so the king
definitely has to stop that
King takes Pawn
if this guy keeps running check this
position now each of these past pawns
are two steps away from queening one way
or the other
this guy is either going to promote and
give check or this guy is going to be
able to promote and give check black is
simply faster at this stage so I don't
know if you go here
you know you're going to promote with
check
if you go here
we're going to have this promotion with
check and then we're going to be given
check along the back rank black wins the
race so
the king and pawn endings are all
working out here for team black this is
a great maneuver here by the night in
the event
in this position right here
in the event of King F2 we go Knight F5
Knight E3 and that's a beautiful pivot
on D1
in this game it is King D3 and the G2
Pawn is simply scooped up in a few moves
black made progress here on the king
side gave himself winning chances it is
now it has been now for a few moves ever
since Bishop to E1 it has been a win for
black
Knight F5
Bishop F2 no time to uh come over at
this stage the king now has a
responsibility defend D4
Bishop F2 Knight H4
Trading
again Bishop for Knight is going to be a
win
we've already been in this situation
before so
the pawn is simply one
A5 is tried and Knight takes Pawn the
black King enters
and how do you stop F2
in general you should be positioning
your Bishop on a diagonal where it has
the most Mobility
so
he tries Bishop to G3
has three options along this diagonal
whereas this one only gives the bishop
or four options versus this diagonal
here with three
Bishop G3 in this game and only one
final move
Knight E3
in white resigns
these two under control by the king and
next up the knight's gonna go here
and control these two squares
the bishop will not be able to sacrifice
itself
for the pawn
this guy will be queening
so with this win
this put Fisher at a perfect
out of 11. 11 games
11 wins here's a look at the standings
from this event
how do you set an unbreakable record
there's only one way you could do that
and that is to go perfect
that's exactly what he did in this event
and it has yet to happen again and
there's even a prize now nowadays with
the U.S Championship should anyone match
this record
congratulations
uh you've earned the Fisher prize
you've increased your bank account by 64
a thousand dollars
okay that's the incentive for going
perfect at this event
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below
I hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye